but we wanted to celebrate their  announcement on our stage since this is  a game that Playstation bands have been  very very very vocal about  [Music]  see Tony demo dr. sadira da-da-da-da-da  it's a city  Dorinda toca Cano say oh sorry text  Akita keep the started a famous video  scooter go Tony  to me master  the attention would soon on Suzuki  guiding their arnica time to start a new  run absolutely story like the killer  cotton madness shamelessly will be the  story you have wait for but this  Kickstarter will be real success when  you choose to make it the full ocean  experience you have dreams of the fate  of Shenmue is in your hands now  [Music]